تقول إدارة شرطة مدينة نيويورك
إن السرقة في هذا الفيديو
مرتبطة بنمط سرقة على مستوى المدينة،
وتم القبض على سبعة مهاجرين على الأقل
بعد تنفيذ مذكرة تفتيش في
منزل في برونكس، وتقول شرطة نيويورك إن المشتبه بهم
جزء من مؤسسة إجرامية
يستخدم في المقام الأول الدراجات البخارية المسروقة لسرقة
الهواتف ثم يخترق تلك الهواتف لسرقة
الأموال وإجراء معاملات غير قانونية
لوضع هذا في الاعتبار
منذ الأول من يناير 2024، كان لدينا 32
نمطًا مفتوحًا يتضمن Reds
وخطف الهواتف مقارنة بنمط واحد في هذا الوقت من
العام الماضي وهو 147 حالة و  أي ما يعادل
147 ضحية، ليس من الواضح ما إذا كان
المهاجرين الذين تم القبض عليهم غير موثقين أو
طالبي لجوء. الأمر لا يتعلق
بالمهاجرين وطالبي اللجوء، بل يتعلق
بالمجرمين الذين ارتكبوا جريمة
وسنعامل المجرمين بنفس الطريقة إذا
كانوا من سكان نيويورك منذ فترة طويلة أو إذا
وصلوا للتو  هنا العام الماضي